so far we've talked about how kubeflow
pipelines bring orchestration for
complex ml workflows
giving you reproducible and reliable
experimentation
and in our last episode i showed you a
prediction model ready to go
let's walk through building a keyflow
pipeline that uses this model
today we'll go through a sample ml app
using pipelines
check out the link below if you want to
read more about building pipelines in a
jupiter notebook
i'll use the same model from the last
episode where you'll forecast how many
chicago crimes are expected to be
reported the next day
based on how many were reported over the
previous days if you want to see more
details on the model itself
check out the last video to create an ml
app on kubeflow we'll walk through
downloading data from bigquery creating
a qflo pipeline
including google cloud ai platform
components to train and deploy the model
submitting a job for execution and
sharing the pipeline with others
ai platform is google cloud's solution
to train ml models at scale
host your trained models and serve
models to make new predictions
we're going to run this all from a
jupiter notebook server running on
kubeflow
on a running notebook clone the github
repo linked below and access the ai
platform notebook
if you run into any authentication
issues while running the notebook
make sure you're on the latest version
of kubeflow and check out the
documentation around the user gcp
essay secret getting started with the
notebook code
will import dependencies and define
constants including the kubeflow sdk
as you begin to create your pipeline
first define the required parameters
like the google cloud project id
and storage bucket optional parameters
include your storage path containing
your untrained model
the output storage bucket pipeline name
and model name
similar to the chicago crimes notebook
we covered last time start by defining a
download function that will download
trainer data
from google cloud bigquery this time
you'll be using the bigquery kubeflow
pipeline component
remember that components include inputs
and outputs
which can become inputs to other
components this component submits a
query to the bigquery service and dumps
output to our cloud storage bucket
next pre-process the data and submit a
training job to ai platform
remember each step in a pipeline is a
containerized task
this means that every component must be
packaged as a container
to do this you can load a pipeline
component via a local file or a
component url
like a github commit making sharing
versions and reuse easy
in this example we call a yaml file that
defines our next component
which submits a training job to ai
platform while this is one way to
package a component that makes sharing
easier
there are other ways to do this like
using the pipeline's sdk
which includes classes and methods for
interacting with pipeline components
inputs for this component include the
cloud storage location of our model
the input parameters to create a
training job and the container image uri
to run this component it outputs a job
id
and storage path to the trained model
the next component will deploy the model
with the id from our last output
this yaml file describes a pipeline
component to deploy our trained model
from cloud storage to an ai platform
service
inputs include the cloud storage path of
the trained model and it outputs the
storage path containing our deployed
model
now you can string together all of these
components to define the kubeflow
pipeline
just define the data set storage path
and trainer output storage path
and call the download data function
training function
and model deployment function finally
submit the pipeline for execution
the keyflow pipeline system requires an
experiment to group pipeline runs
if you don't specify an experiment it
will use the default one
it outputs a link to both the experiment
and the run on kubeflow
once you finish waiting for the pipeline
to complete you can see it in the qflo
console plus related logs from the run
here we've added a line of code to
compile our pipeline so we can share it
with others
once you run it you can locate the zip
file in your notebook server and
download it
the archive file can be shared with
others which lets them run it on their
own kubeflow clusters
you can upload a pipeline file to the
qlo pipelines page with versioning
control built in
once uploaded you can create runs from
the same ui and qflow has a form to fill
out input parameters so you can start
runs
right away giving you reusability at
your fingertips
once you've deployed the pipeline and
tested it you can share the archive file
so your teams can deploy it on the
production cluster
in addition to sharing the whole
pipeline you can also share the
component files
making steps shareable and reusable stay
tuned to learn where else you can run
[Music]
pipelines
you